une large victoire 15 touches à 7 et
dans la foulée cette image l'Ukrainienne
Olga carlann ici à gauche présente son
sabre à la fin de la rencontre pour un
toucher de l'âme avec son adversaire
russe mais refuse de lui tendre la main
face à elle Anas mirnova proteste et
reste assise sur la piste de longues
minutes avant d'avoir gain de cause les
scrimeuse ukrainienne et disqualifié
pour ce geste interdit par le règlement
nous avons déjà soumis notre
protestation au bureau de la Fédération
internationale d'escrime nous attendons
la prise en compte immédiate de cette
protestation afin que sa
disqualification soit annulée école gap
puisse participer aux compétitions par
équipe
il s'agissait du tout premier duel en
escrime entre ukrainien et russe qui est
venait tout juste d'autoriser ces
sportifs à affronter des rues soubiers
russes qui concourent sous bannière
neutre
le plus important et qu'elle a montré la
position
ukrainienne nous ne pouvons pas serrer
la main de nos ennemis
c'est pourquoi il est très important
pour nous que pendant les Jeux
olympiques de Paris il n'y ait pas de
russe ou de biélorus sous leur drapeau
qu'il n'y ait pas de symbole le Comité
international olympique a lui appelé à
faire preuve de sensibilité avec les
sportifs Ukrainiens pour les jeux de
paris 2024 la décision d'intégrer ou non
les sportifs russes et biélorusses se
fait toujours attendre Kief décidera
ensuite d'un boycott ou non de ces JO